all right what is up guys my name is
Peter paw and we're playing some tennis
match on launch it's a really awesome
game actually and I was surprised it
turned out so well cuz this first one a
half minute I [ __ ] up really bad they
like I was tired I was a really focused
I was just you know oh there's a guy I
guess I shoot him but I don't know
something happened I stepped up my game
some Sparkle lit up or something so I'm
actually trying out a setup that I
talked about in the previous video and I
said to myself like is it a good idea to
use warlord and dual mags with
suppressor because I keep running out of
ammo and I don't really want to use
ghost no that was wrong I want to use
ghost but I don't wanna use scavenger
but I keep running out of ammo because
I'm only always wanna use the suppressor
almost almost yell at least so the idea
was to use dual mags and hopefully not
run out of ammo all the time and you
know it's replacing steady aim because
honestly I don't really hip fire that
much anyway so you know I'm fine with it
and I'm actually actually not really
sure do you aim down the sights quicker
if you don't have the any scope one also
that was what I was wondering and with
sleight of hand and
if you know please let me know because I
don't really feel like testing it out I
only I really like using all over used
stuff and which like the stadium works
pretty well anyway but it's fun to test
out different stuff and it worked it
worked out really well so I'm kind of
happy about it and about my teammates as
you see in this for were pretty far
behind and that's pretty much how the
entire game goes I want I don't want to
say that my team which mates were bad
but and they died a lot and I guess they
had a bad day or something I don't know
i only get pissed off at my teammates if
they in the way or something like that
that sounds really and a self-centered
or something but I don't know it's a
video game really and yeah i'm using the
famas and i think vamos is like probably
one of the best assault rifles
it's kind of leaning between the AK or
gal deal I guess it depends on your
peripheral per day per for all personal
preference and I'm pick up the ak-74 you
here even though I said it was going to
use it in another video but I ran out of
ammo so what are you gonna do and I do
use dogs this time around and because I
wanted to switch things up a little bit
and i get no kills with them I got three
kills but it seems pretty insignificant
to since I it get so many more kills
with the shop again I don't know this
feels unfair om new got the shop we
gonna yet there was actually a guy who
commented in my loss no couple of videos
ago he said that he saw thought it
wasn't fun that I used a shop regarding
for some reason and I don't know what to
say like it's part of the game and it's
not that I [ __ ] my pants over the
killstreak like it's their fun but you
know I wouldn't be crying if that
weren't in the game I didn't really I
didn't really miss them when i play
blacklight tango down so it's fun but
yeah probably why people are hating on
them is because they die of them so
that's how I make sense of it and
they should it down anyway so doesn't
really matter
and yeah now i think it's when i get my
doubts and my dog hates me I got no case
I hate them they hate me I don't know
why I do wrong with them or something
and
I kind of Miss the nuke though in modern
warfare two I remember when I got my
first nuke I was so excited I was
screaming and everything I was like mom
you have to come see this she was like
what is it son oh my love you got a nuke
I am so proud of you I don't know what
I'm talking about yeah also the famas it
looks so weird like what is that thing
on the left side it looks like a shovel
or something I don't know why it would
put a shovel on your gum though there's
probably some maybe it's when you're
lying prone or something you put it down
it sucks that you don't really use it
seems pretty it's just there dangling
whatever that's what she said or
something I don't know I don't know and
so yeah
what else did I want to talk about it's
someday probably for you as well and I
really like Sunday's because then i miss
my parents attic on sundays and they
they give me real food you know i am not
really a good chef i just recently moved
out of my parents house and it's
annoying to cook all the time for
yourself so i love whenever someone is
treating me dinner yeah yeah i don't
know what's up with this position I am
at it's like they can't see more
something and I should have seen that
guy was on the UAV but doesn't really
matter see I got my second chopper
Shabri so empowered but you know they
still I don't think I get as many kills
this time around
and I kind of failed that I didn't get
the dogs but you know the dogs just
given me any kills anyway so and I
really like this map this map is so cool
like with the rocket launch and all that
it's they really I have to say this one
a cool this map I've seen in a
multiplayer and it's not my favorite map
but it's really cool and I have to give
them some the guys who developed it to
some credit because and it's so much fun
because a lot of people tend to camp
beneath the rocket or whatever [ __ ] it
is and it's so much fun on section is
wrong people camped there and then the
when the rocket launched every one of
the campers died I think that's
hilarious it's like campers your nod and
and also like as the map is pretty
symmetric so each spawn is on each side
so unless you're rushing their spawn you
can pretty much stay at the same spot
and you know I don't have to run around
you're looking for enemies entire
[ __ ] game which is pretty annoying
and so yeah I'm pretty much thing at
this position and most of the game and
they can't really see me I don't why
something is wrong it's like I'm
invisible keep looking forward and
that's pretty I guess that's a
beginner's mistake to not to just focus
on one thing but
all in my favor and that guy pop this
head out like it's [ __ ] West and a
video game or surfing lesson shooter so
yeah the via the not the video yeah the
video is about to end and I hope you
have a nice Sunday you're awesome for
watching and I think I get the last
killcam shoot him in the feet for the
foot I mean for the win and yeah if you
like the video please go ahead and
subscribe and I rate if you want to and
other than that happen having a nice
sunday i already said that but the final
score is 48 for i thought it was pretty
good except that I died in beginning so
many times but yeah see you tomorrow
baha